(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Just a few
weeks ago on September 22nd
a group of Egyptians
raised the rainbow flag
at Mashrou' Leila concert.
This led to the widest
crackdown and arrests
of LGBT individuals in Egypt.
Regarding human rights violations
the victims have been
dealing with physical abuse,
beatings, groping, cursing.
They've also had limitations
put on their family
and legal visitations.
They've also had anal examinations.
This treatment is tantamount to torture.
Now, according to the UN, any arrests
based on gender identity
or sexual orientation
are by definition arbitrary, and therefore
violate International law.
(gentle music)
The Egyptian media has
an immediate response
after every crackdown
by making the queer identity
synonymous with terrorism,
debauchery and prostitution.
(foreign language)
People have been using scare tactics
and propaganda since
the beginning of time.
It's our responsibility to
look past these scare tactics
and see humanity instead.
On a bright note, eyes
are on Egypt right now
showing solidarity and support.
And protests are occurring
all over the world.
You have queer people, queer Egyptians
who may have located to other
countries outside of their own
and they're getting attention.
And they're getting support
and love and solidarity.
And they may have been
existing this entire time
with that same fear instilled in them.
There are queer Egyptians
around the world right now
looking over and feeling visible
and feeling seen and heard and love.
To my siblings suffering in
prison, you're not alone.
To my queer family around
the globe, you're not alone.
Your suffering is not gonna go unheard.
We are working really hard to make sure
that these human rights
violations don't occur again.
And to those already in prison for this
we're working hard to get you out.
Look for links below to
show support and solidarity.
There are so many
organizations and initiatives
beginning and springing up.
And if you want to start your own,
that would be amazing too.
(foreign language)
- Bring hope back to Egypt.
- Bring pride back to Egypt.
- Bring love back to Egypt.
- I'm a naval veteran and
I stand with queer Egypt.
- I stand with queer Egypt.
(foreign language)
- Bring pride back to Egypt.
- I'm with queer Egypt.
I love you guys, I stand with you guys.
We're here, we're thinking
of you and we love you.